[Music]
it's time for friday night's press
preview it's our first look at the front
pages of saturday's papers and tonight
we're checking out the headlines with
huffpost uk's political editor kevin
schofield and the sun's deputy political
editor kate ferguson they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight a
very good evening to both of you we'll
chat in a moment after we've had a look
at the front pages starting with the
ft
leading with the lengthy inbound cues to
the port of dover caused by delays with
post-brexit border checks
the telegraph reports that foreign
secretary and prime ministerial
candidate liz truss
has told french authorities that the
tailbacks are unacceptable and that they
must get the situation under control
the star conveys the frustrations of
younger passengers in those queues
asking are we nearly there yet
on that same story the mail proclaims
wish you weren't here
and the mirror has the simple headline
holes chaos
the eye carries a prediction from the
economist patrick minford that liz
truss's tax policies could mean interest
rates reach as high as seven percent
the express splashes with a poll
suggesting liz truss would beat zakir
stama in a general election
while the guardian says that hundreds of
laws on employment and environmental
protection could be scrapped if liz
trust carries out her pledge to ax all
remaining eu regulations
meanwhile our opponent wishisounak has
given an interview to the times in which
he declares that britain is in a state
of national emergency given the current
landscape of the economy the nhs and
illegal immigration
and the sun has word that tv
personalities paddy and christine
mcginnis are ending their marriage
and don't forget you can scan the qr
code you can see on screen join the
program and you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers along with us
and tonight i'm joined by kevin
schofield and kate ferguson lovely to
see you this friday evening pretty much
all the front pages
are covering the chaos that many holiday
makers face today as they headed to
dover uh kevin the front of the mail
wish you weren't here really really bad
start to the holiday isn't it for so
many families
yeah it's all following the timing could
hardly be worse and you feel really
sorry
for all those families and the kids have
just gone off on holiday you know
looking forward to getting away after a
pretty tough couple of years maybe their
first holiday abroad for a couple years
probably trying to avoid the airports
after reading about all the
trouble and getting flights i think
they'll try and get around that by going
via dover and getting snarled up with
them
lots of traffic jams down there as well
uh it just feels like there's
been a massive breakdown
in the process essentially for
enabling people to get from the uk into
france all sorts of accusations being
thrown around by
the uk government accusing france have
been ill prepared
not having
the correct border officials there to
process passports france saying that
noah was a technical issue
uh in the channel tunnel um and it's
just a real mess and obviously
unfortunately for the people who are
left affected by it you know stuck in
traffic jams for up to six hours kids
fractures kids in the back seat
obviously not very happy the weather's
pretty warm
and it's just a pretty miserable start
start
to the people's summer holidays yeah we
were debating in the newsroom which
you'd rather do be stuck in an airport
with miserable kids or be stuck in a car
with miserable kids i'm not quite sure
which one is better uh in front of the
daily star kate uh are we nearly there
yet sort of echoing what kevin was
saying uh there and there is this real
blame game going on
yeah i mean it's really grim isn't it
it's meant to be the first day of the
big summer getaway and you've got seven
hour queues at dover i think people
heading there and their cars were being
told to stock up on food and water
before you get here some quite stark
warnings but as predicted you know as
soon as things like this happens a
bitter brain flame game immediately
erupts so you have the brits blaming the
french we're saying
the guy that runs the port of dover is
saying france woefully failed to turn up
with enough staff to man there's a boost
where you would go through border checks
france are hitting back insisting that
they had planned for this day
for a long time but that a technical
glitch apparently sent everything south
about 9am and that they've never managed
to get on top of the tailbacks that
caused but interestingly we're seeing
this trust who we'll talk more about
tonight i'm sure but the the woman vying
to be the next prime minister but is
currently a foreign secretary going in
quite studs up on the french telling
them it's unacceptable totally avoidable
and that they should sort it out now
while the blame game rages i think
brit stuck in those kind of horrific
queues will just want it sorted out and
sorted out as quickly as possible but it
looks like it's going to stick around at
least for a few days warnings
um by some of the travel companies that
we could face four hour delays tomorrow
still so oh gosh yeah really grim really
grim um it's interesting kevin adam
parsons our europe correspondent saying
tonight that sources are telling him
that extra french personnel
were brought in as planned
but they were late
because they went to folkestone and on
their way to dover got stuck in traffic
i mean you couldn't make it up could you
um but he was also saying
making the point that you know in the
past
before brexit you sort of could just
wave your passport pretty much to get
through whereas now you have to have it
physically stamped and that is slowing
the situation down it's sort of
reflected in the ft uh row over post
brexit border checks hits big holiday
getaway
yeah that's right so i think even if
everything was working as it should
things would still take a little bit
longer and then they would have done
pre-brexit as you see because people
have to get the passport stamp now
rather than just showing them to the to
the passport um
staff but as i understand i think that
there should have been 12
booths there manned by
french border officials but only half of
them were man so you know you add that
to the fact that you know as we say you
have to get a passport as well that just
adds a further delay on to it which you
know if it's for that for each person
and there's thousands of cars trying to
get through it all adds up to you know
these um tailbacks are lasting up to six
hours which must be absolutely
horrendous
for families concerns so yeah
as i said things would have been a
little bit slower as a result of brexit
however
you can't just blame brexit for what has
happened uh earlier today and this case
says it's probably going to continue for
quite some time yeah it's just a new
procedure isn't it and and clearly
they're they're still sort of trying to
work out the details when it gets
incredibly busy
and talking about customs issues let's
move on to the story in the daily
express uh kate regarding the northern
ireland protocol
yeah i mean we've had this bubbling
along for a while haven't we we're we in
britain obviously tearing up parts of
the brexit deal the northern ireland
protocol without wanting to get too
bogged down in the detail this is at a
big row about
again excessive checks excessive border
checks on goods going between the
mainland gb and northern ireland britain
has said we're going to
tear up that protocol effectively
so that you can have free movement of
goods between
gb and ni that's obviously caused a
massive blistering rail of the eu and
right in the middle of this tory
leadership debate they've announced
they're going to go ahead and sue us for
breaching the brexit deal now there's a
few cases rumbling in on in the courts
here but i think if you look at the
politics of it it's interesting the eu
have done this now brexit will play
quite a big role in this tory leadership
contest and both candidates taking quite
a hard line saying they would pursue
this policy of tearing up the protocol
that it's important we stand up to the
eu and sort these problems of trade out
and so this seems to be the eu
asserting i guess quite early on in this
contest that
they're not going to roll over and take
that and that they're willing and ready
to have a big dust up with us in the
courts about it yeah kevin a quick
thought on this before we head to the
break
yeah well as actually an opportunity i
think for both total leadership
candidates you know to to stamp their
progress credentials probably more
pressure on liz trust given as we know
she campaigned for remain back in 2016
and she she doesn't really miss an
opportunity to to stress that now she's
fully on board with the whole brexit
project
okay great thank you for the moment uh
coming up after the break is rishi sunak
right to say that britain is in a state
of national emergency that and other
tory leadership stories when we come
back
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me kevin scofield and kate
ferguson front page of the times uh kate
i mean the next two weeks i think are
going to be pretty crucial aren't they
in the leadership uh contest rishi sunak
has got some ground to make up and he's
making a big pitch in the paper and he's
saying that britain faces a national
emergency on a number of fronts
yeah exactly so we're into the tory
leadership leadership contest in earnest
now it goes over to the tory grassroots
so expect lots more big interviews from
the two contenders laying out their
stall this is rishi soon that's kind of
first big policy interview i'd say he's
had less to say on policy than liz and
he's saying a few things number one it's
an economic emergency he says number two
he says he's gonna concentrate on doing
three things focusing on the economy
clearing the nhs backlog and restoring
order to our borders
and his kind of guts of the policy
announcement he's doing today is that
nhs backlog announcement so he's saying
i'm going to create a vaccine-style task
force i will get waiting list times down
by the beginning of next year and i'll
bring this kind of brewing crisis under
control
to my mind it'd be interesting to hear
what kevin thinks too but i think that's
quite a clever idea of rishi tsunak so
he's obviously come under massive
pressure in recent weeks about the fact
that he backed this national insurance
contribution rise this big tax rise to
fund the nhs and i think what we're
seeing richie here do is double down on
that and wrap himself in the nhs flag
and he's trying to create
clear dividing line between him and liz
trust there which i think is probably
quite clever you can't sort of out tax
cut liz trust she's offering 34 billion
pounds of tax cuts so you've got to
embrace
your offering really and give voters a
clear choice
yeah it's interesting uh kevin isn't it
because so much of the debate so far has
been on economic policy and clearly he's
now trying to pitch uh other policies
in order to try and sway some of those
party members who aren't sure about him
yeah i think you hit the nail right in
the head at the beginning there he said
it's only going to be a couple of weeks
before these ballot papers go out and
then
obviously a lot of members will send
those ballot papers back straight away
so
um you know there's really precious
little time
for
rishi sunak to be able to um change
people's minds you know before they
actually vote um and i mean i did have a
little chuckle when i saw the front page
as well you kind of tend to forget that
you know these guys have been in power
for quite some time so if the company's
in a national emergency you wonder whose
fault was that i mean russia sunic was
chancellor for a couple of years and
he's talking about an economic crisis
and i'm not sure that reflects terribly
well in his time in charge and honestly
you can say he had the pandemic to
contend with however um you know it's
just a little bit um ironic i think that
both him and liz trusts are now saying
they are the change candidates when both
of them have been
central parts of the government for for
quite some time yeah that's a good point
um kate uh the front of the eye now most
people i'm sure haven't heard of
professor patrick minford uh but he's
causing quite a stir isn't he tell us
why
yeah this kind of economics professor
that's been thrown onto the front pages
the past couple of days he's one of liz
truss's favorite economic expert she
quoted him approvingly only earlier this
week anyway he's gone and given an
interview and admitted that liz truss's
big tax giveaway
will
fuel inflation and will lead to big
interest rates rises so he's suggesting
it could see interest rates go up to
about seven percent which would
obviously be a massive increase if
you've
got a home trying to pay the mortgage i
think some of the mortgage experts
quoted in the i front page that you just
showed there suggestion suggesting it
could clobber families with another 700
quid on their monthly mortgage bill
which is eye-watering amounts just as
obviously the cost of living crisis
bites
not very useful interview for liz trust
she's her team have been distancing
themselves from his comments today
insisting that yes while she has quoted
the economist he's not a formal advisor
to her but
yeah again you're seeing these clear
dividing lines between the two camps
aren't you do you believe this trust can
do these tax giveaways and it be pain
free like liz says or do you subscribe
to richie sunilac's way of thinking
which is oh you sort of have to kind of
grim and bear good and bear it with the
economic crunch that we're suffering now
because tax giveaways could have other
punitive consequences on your interest
rates and mortgage bills yeah although
uh he does say they will come eventually
doesn't he let's finish with the front
of the daily express again talk about
liz trust they've done an exclusive poll
uh kevin who say that voters uh back her
to beat kia stammer in a general
election
yeah although if you look at the detail
i think it's one percentage point
between
uh between her and starmar so it's well
within the margin of error and we're
obviously a couple years out from a
general election however as undoubtedly
good news for liz trust me one of rishi
sunak's
strong arguments has been that he is um
he is the most likely candidate to be
able to to beat labour at the next
general election because
that's another thing that conservative
members have now got to make their minds
up about it's not just who's going to
lead the conservative party who's going
to be the next prime minister for the
next
year or 18 months is who is going to
lead the party into the next general
election and
up to 10 11 points behind labour right
now so um but yeah it is a boost
for liz trusts and again it just puts
versus sunic on the back foot because it
puts a doubt
in members minds about whether he is
actually the guy who can
beat a labor at the next election uh so
again as i was saying earlier he doesn't
have a lot of time to try and convince
twenty members that
he's the guy that
that they should vote for and this poll
certainly won't won't help him okay just
a couple of sentences on this kate
you've been richie sunax big pitch his
main pitch is vote for me i'm the only
guy that can be kirstarma if we start
seeing more polls show that liz trust
can as well it massively chips away at
that whole selling point and will be a
problem for him but let's see what the
polls say